[Music]
beetles don't fold their wings
quite like other animals they lack the
muscles that bats and birds use
to adjust wing shape and protect their
wings
even without that capacity beetles can
navigate dense forests
rapidly recovering after knocking into
branches
that makes them a good model for
efficient flapping wing robots that can
survive obstacles
a new study looked closely at the flight
of rhinoceros beetles
hoping the crawly creature's hind wings
could inform the design of a small
tough flyer scientists ran tests of
beetles in flight
and found that their wings passively
unfolded and locked into place
mid-course simply thanks to their
aerodynamic design
this allowed them to recover after
collisions as part of their forward
flight
when wing folding was restricted the
beetles tumbled to the ground
the scientists ran similar tests on a
robot equipped with beetle-like wings
without a wing folding mechanism
collisions made the robot spin out of
control
but when employed passive wing folding
kept the robot stable
post-collision this technology might be
useful
in cluttered search and rescue missions
like finding people
trapped within collapsed buildings
not bad for a beetlebot